jeffrey epstein commits suicide within
days of being taken off suicide watch
conspiracy theorists including the
president jump on board
and democrats launch some conspiracies
of their own i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
oh we apologize for the slight delay in
bringing you today's show i had to
forcibly take over andrew clavin's
studio and expel him physically
from that studio the good news is i own
the studios there's nothing he can do
about that we'll get to the news
in just one second first you may have
noticed that the economy seems like it's
on the brink of something there are
banks today bank of america suggesting
there's a one in three chance of a
recession there's a lot of geopolitical
tension
ranging from iran to china obviously
tariffs are impacting the markets in a
heavy way
this might be a good time for you to
diversify into gold can you afford
another hit to your retirement like the
last downturn when the s p
dropped 50 now i know the folks over at
birch gold i trust the folks over at
birch gold with my precious metals
investment it's a great way to hedge
against inflation
hedge against uncertainty and
instability precious metals doesn't mean
take all your money out of stocks and
bonds and then toss them
into precious metals means at least a
little bit of your money should be in
precious metals
my savings plan is diversified and yours
should be as well the company i trust
with precious metal purchases birch gold
group look back historically when the
bottom falls out of everything else
gold does tend to safeguard savings
birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers
countless five star reviews and a plus
rating with the better business bureau
contact birch gold group right now get
that free information kit on physical
precious metals
see if diversifying into gold and silver
makes sense for you
it's a comprehensive 16-page kit shows
how gold and silver can protect your
savings
text ben my name to 47-47-47 to get that
no cost no obligation kit again
text ben to 47 47 47 and get in touch
with the folks over birch gold ask all
your questions they're good people i
know them
check them out birchgold.com and check
them out text ben my name
to 47 47 47 okay so obviously
the big news on this monday morning is
the death of jeffrey epstein jeffrey
epstein of course the convicted
pedophile who was recently re-arrested
on federal charges
of sex trafficking there's a lot of
worry in the nation's highest corridors
of power
about what exactly jeffrey epstein might
say in fact just on friday
there was a federal court that unsealed
documents from a lawsuit
by one of jeffrey epstein's accuser
against his mysterious girlfriend and
alleged procurer
zhizlane maxwell so the accuser name is
virginia giufri
accused maxwell of procuring young girls
for sexual abuse by epstein and his
powerful friends
according to the daily beast some of the
major revelations include
in 2016 jewfrey said that maxwell
specifically
instructed her to serve former new
governor new mexico governor bill
richardson who at one point
was a front-running democratic
presidential candidate britain's prince
andrew
wealthy financier glenn dubin former
senate majority leader george mitchell
modeling jean-luc brunel and scientist
marvin minsky
geoffrey also said that maxwell and
epstein directed her to have sex with
another prince
a foreign president a well-known prime
minister and the owner of a large
hotel chain none of the men named have
been charged with a crime
and all have denied inappropriate
behavior
apparently there are also accusations
according to
another one of the another one of the
women who dealt with epstein that
epstein was basically sexually voracious
and thus preyed on girls at an insane
rate
ju juan alessi epstein former house
manager testified he saw probably over a
hundred girls serve epstein at his palm
beach home over 10 years
after each encounter unless he said he
would clean up the home's upstairs
massage room
on multiple occasions he said he found
sex toys and put them in maxwell's
closet because he knew that's where they
kept such items
along with a shiny black costume this is
all
really disgusting obviously and these
revelations came as of friday so there
were a lot of there's a lot of talk
about whose name was going to drop next
what were the next steps
in the epstein trial within 24 hours of
all of that dropping jeffrey epstein
allegedly committed suicide and
apparently committed suicide
he was just 11 days removed from being
on suicide watch according to cbs news
epstein who is facing federal sex
trafficking charges died saturday from
an apparent suicide
federal official said the federal bureau
of prisons said in a statement the fbi
was investigating his death epstein who
is 66
was found unresponsive in his cell at a
holding facility
in new york city at around 6 30 a.m
according to the statement
staff at the metropolitan correctional
center tried to revive him he was
eventually taken to a hospital where he
was pronounced dead the new york city
medical examiner's office was also
investigating epstein's cause of death a
spokesperson
told cbs news and will conduct an
autopsy and toxicology test to determine
the cause there's a statement put out by
the medical examiner's office saying
they were still going to determine cause
of death that doesn't mean they suspect
homicide it means they still have to
finally determine cause of death
although they think they know what
happened here
federal prosecutors in new york alleged
epstein abused dozens of underage girls
as young as 14 epstein was found injured
on the floor of his cell in late july
at the time law enforcement sources told
cbs news that epstein was found
semi-conscious with slight bruising
around his neck so apparently he tried
to hang himself
at that juncture and he was put on
suicide watch
so there's all sorts of of weird stuff
surrounding this particular suicide and
it's leading a lot of people
toward conspiracy theories the chief
medical examiner dr barbara sampson
released a statement on sunday
saying that her office had conducted an
autopsy on epstein but the medical
examiner's determination is pending
further information
at this time she said this is routine
she said i allowed a private pathologist
to observe the autopsy which is routine
my office defers to the involved law
enforcement agencies regarding other
investigations
around this death a lot of epstein's
victims are
upset because they felt like this was
their chance at justice
attorney general william barr says the
investigation will continue there are
associates and co-conspirators with
epstein
who will in fact be on the hook for
whatever crimes they committed so this
thing does not end with epstein being
dead
this sex trafficking case
was very important to the department of
justice and to me
personally but let me assure you
that this case will continue on against
anyone who was complicit with epstein
any co-conspirators should not rest easy
the victims deserve justice and they
will get it
so the conspiracy chatter picked up
almost immediately you had dueling
hashtags
on twitter that were trending one was
trump body count and the other was
clinton body account there's accusations
by the right
that clinton body count wasn't trending
because twitter is biased to the left
certainly twitter is biased to the left
i don't know why that wasn't trending
the fact is this was neither trump nor
clinton by all available evidence
but you saw that implication put forward
by a variety of sources msnbc's joy reid
actually suggested that attorney general
william barr
might be covering up epstein's death at
trump's behest because trump of course
is friends with jeffrey epstein
the investigation of epstein's death now
falls into the hands
of william barr donald trump's
consigliere an attorney general
who refused to recuse himself on the
epstein case despite
his association with a law firm once
involved with epstein
whose father once hired jeffrey epstein
as a teacher with neither experience nor
degree
and whose prime directive is to protect
donald
trump no matter what okay so there she
is putting out her own conspiracy theory
then president trump in his own
inimitable
fashion decided you know it'd be a great
idea i'm going to retweet whatever i
feel like and
i feel like retweeting a wild conspiracy
theory so he retweeted
a tweet from a guy named terrence
williams on twitter
and the tweet says died of suicide on 24
suicide watch yeah right how does that
happen
jeffrey epstein had information on bill
clinton and now he's dead
i see trump body count trending but we
know who did this retweet if you're not
surprised
epstein's suicide hashtag
clintonbodycount hashtag clintoncrime
family and then he released a little
video discussing why he thought that the
clintons
had murdered jeffrey epstein now this
has been a long-standing meme on the
right is that the clintons routinely
murder their political opponents
not a lot of evidence to suggest that
that is true despite widespread
speculation about
characters including vince foster for
example
president trump tweeted that out and um
that was awkward here's a little bit of
that terence williams video in which he
talks about all of this shaking my head
i'm not surprised i told y'all last
month this was gonna happen
but didn't nobody want to listen to me
but then guess what next month he did
and you know what all the liberals were
calling me a conspiracy theory saying
terence
you coming up with crazy conspiracies
and you need to be
banned from twitter and then guess what
the man really ended up dead
and you know what he had he had
information on the clintons
and the man okay that's enough of that
so trump actually retweeted that
trump actually retweeted that now number
one this wasn't the clintons okay as we
will see
this is wild incompetence by jail
officers which
frankly is not all that uncommon i mean
it is it is unfortunate truth of life
that human beings are wildly incompetent
generally and is also another
unfortunate truth that treatment in
american prisons
it depends on the prison but many
prisons are horribly run the guards
don't do their jobs
to the apex of their abilities they feel
like they're dealing with criminals and
therefore they sort of slack off a bit
that's not an indictment of all prison
officers by any measure a lot of prison
officers probably the vast majority of
prison officers do their job
with honor and diligence but there are
going to be some who do not
obviously and this one falls under han
handling's razor never attribute to
malevolence that which you can attribute
to human stupidity
and while this all looks very suspicious
because obviously epstein was the most
watched federal prisoner
in america still i am much more inclined
to chalk this up to prison guards didn't
do their job
then bill and hillary clinton sneaked
somebody into jeffrey epstein's cell
to kill him in his cell i mean the lady
couldn't even find wisconsin on a map
i i don't think that this has to do with
hillary clinton and bill clinton
deciding that it's time for jeffrey
epstein to be offed
why wouldn't they often before he was
arrested i mean the whole thing doesn't
make any sense
and as it turns out there's lots of
evidence of incompetence here
apparently according to the associated
press guards on jeffrey epstein's unit
were working extreme overtime shifts to
make up for staffing shortages the
morning of his apparent suicide
a person familiar with the jails
operations told the associated press
the person said that the metropolitan
correctional center's special housing
unit
was staffed with one guard working a
fifth straight day of overtime
and another who was working mandatory
overtime the person wasn't authorized to
discuss jail operations publicly
spoke sunday on the condition of
anonymity epstein's abrupt death cuts
short of criminal prosecution that could
have pulled back the curtain on the
inner workings of a high-flying
financier with connections to
celebrities and presidents
the jail staff followed failed to follow
protocols
leading up to epstein's death according
to a report from the new york times
deepening the fallout from what led to
his apparent suicide the new york times
reports that epstein was supposed to
have been checked by
two guards in the protective housing
unit every 30 minutes
he was alone in a cell just 11 days
after he'd been taken off suicide watch
that was not supposed to happen he was
supposed to have somebody else in the
cell with him
the procedure of him being checked every
30 minutes was not followed that night
because epstein may have tried to commit
suicide three weeks earlier obviously
that other inmate was supposed to be in
there but the jail recently transferred
his cellmate and allowed epstein to be
housed alone a decision that also
violated the jail's procedures
attorney general william barr was
fighting matt about that today as well
he suggested that there could be
prosecution on the table
for negligence for some of the people
who are associated
with all of this in addition according
to the uk daily mail every 15 minutes
guards are required to make another
check
on prisoners who are on suicide watch
the decision to remove epstein from
suicide watch has both baffled former
wardens and veterans of the federal
prison system
alike as matt walsh of daily wire
pointed out
suicide watch is not supposed to be
taken quite so literally you're not
actually supposed to watch while the
person commits suicide so
well done everybody involved now it's
trump's retweet that's getting all the
attention today it is president trump
tweeting out a conspiracy theory that's
getting all the attention we'll get to
that
in just one moment also i wanted to
discuss why it is that generally
people tend to buy conspiracy theories
even though conspiracy theories
rarely end up being true we'll get to
that
in just one moment first these jailers
they had one job
one job and they failed to do it well
here at the daily wire everybody
has a job and they have to do their job
if they don't do their job then we can
quickly and easily replace them
with ziprecruiter.com or we can just
find new people to bring onboard which
we are doing right now actually if
you're looking for a job check out
dailywire.com
careers and check out our job listings
over at zip recruiter zip recruiter
is the best way to find a great employee
zip recruiter will send your job posting
to over 100 of the web's leading job
boards they don't stop there as
applications come in zipper crew
analyzes each one spotlight's the top
candidates so you're never going to miss
a great match
ziprecruiter is so effective that four
out of five employers who post on
ziprecruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the very first
day it's supremely effective right now
my listeners can try ziprecruiter for
free at this exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com dailywire that's
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire w i r d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e
ziprecruiter dot com slash daily why are
zip recorders indeed the smartest way to
hire go check them out right now
ziprecruiter.com dailywire once more
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire hire the way we do here at the
daily wire we have lots of great
employees you can too
ziprecruiter.com dailywire okay so
number one
why do so many people buy into
conspiracy theories like this
there really uh a couple of reasons one
is that social media tends to amplify
conspiracy theories
these days it's very easy to hit retweet
it's very easy for jokes to go viral and
then people to take them seriously
social media tends to take pockets of
fringe opinion
and if there are many pockets out there
a french opinion it then sort of
agglomerates them into one giant fringe
opinion that
starts to look more and more mainstream
and less and less fringe
this is what has happened in pretty much
every area of american life with fringy
opinion
ranging from white supremacism to
conspiracy theorizing
it used to be that you were the weirdo
in your town you're on your own now
you're the weirdo in your town you can
hang out with every weirdo online and
then you can form these kind of giant
blocks
of people who believe in crazy stuff
part of the
rise of conspiracy theories also has to
do with generalized distrust of the
media as we'll get to
the media only seems skeptical of
certain types of conspiracy theories
other types of conspiracy theories the
media are totally
on board with most of this has to do
with the human inability to accept
widespread incompetence
so as i say it is very difficult to
accept incompetence it's much easier
to simply understand that or believe
that people are nefarious that people
are in control one of the harder
revelations in life as we become adults
is recognizing that most people are just
as incompetent as they were when they
were seven years old and picking their
boogers and eating them
they're just adults now so now they're
incompetent and they get paid
and you hope that their incompetence
isn't so off the charts that it actually
harms somebody
people get harmed more often than you
think but going back to the media for a
moment the media were all over trump
for retweeting the conspiracy theory and
that's fair
i mean it's wild but the president of
the united states is retweeting
conspiracy theories about his
lead political opponents the clintons in
2016 murdering somebody in federal
custody
i mean i would say that i'm surprised
except that he accused ted cruz's father
of murdering jfk so i think we've been
here right and this is this is the part
where i remind everybody that it's all
baked into the cake with president trump
this is the part where i remind
everybody that um there's nothing new
here
okay so for everyone who's expecting his
approval rating to plummet
no we had no expectations there were no
expectations that trump would not
retweet something like this does that
make it right no
it's still wrong it's still
unpresidential it's still ridiculous
and the president deserves all the
scrutiny that he's getting trump
deserves every bit of scrutiny he's
getting it's really gross
it's disgusting it's morally
reprehensible for the president to tweet
without any evidence i mean he is the
president of the united states
tweet without evidence that somebody on
the other side is responsible for a
murder or maybe you're responsible for
murder
if barack obama had done it then we
would all be up in arms on the right
now the reason that we're not quite as
up in arms about trump as we are about
obama isn't just because trump is a
republican
it's also because as i've said before
trump is not as serious a human being as
barack obama is
and anybody who says they take trump as
seriously as they take obama is lying to
you
and they're just people in your life you
don't take all that seriously because
they mailed off on a consistent basis
donald trump is one of those people
barack obama was much more planned
so if obama had dropped a line like this
you would have assumed it was part of a
broader scheme
if trump does something like this you
just assume that his id took over for a
moment and he hit the retweet button and
we're done
everybody has sort of baked that in with
regard to trump nonetheless
trump earning the disdain of the media
for this is not unfitting here is george
stephanopoulos over at abc news
suggesting that it is stunning for trump
to insinuate that clinton was complicit
in the epstein suicide
you mentioned the conspiracy that the
u.s attorney is investigating also a lot
of conspiracy theories online one
propagated by president trump himself he
retweeted a tweet that seemed to suggest
that bill clinton
uh was somehow complicit in the death of
of jeffrey epstein uh
it shouldn't go without remarking kind
of stunning that a presidential accusing
his predecessor one of his predecessors
of complicity in murder and the fact is
tommy she spent a lot of time looking at
the jeffrey epstein case
he had relationships both with bill
clinton and donald trump
okay so again it's not wrong for the
media to criticize
president trump for all of this cory
booker then puts on his angry eyes
and he says this is dangerous it's
dangerous very angry
i'm so angry i went out mr potato head
busting through that wall like the
kool-aid man here we go
this is just more recklessness what he's
doing is dangerous
he's giving life to not just conspiracy
theories but
really whipping people up uh into anger
and worse against different people in
this country
and so this is a tired way that the
president does he's been
using the clintons as a means
for a lot of his false accusations but
remember
this is a nation row where we've seen uh
just horrific
acts whether it's someone walking into a
pizza shop based upon
these kind of conspiracy theories to
take violent action
conspiracy theories are dangerous they
are dangerous because they susp
again they suggest that there is
somebody who is nefarious behind the
scenes manipulating everything and if
you took that person out then you would
end the conspiracy it's all three days
of the condor and there's somebody who's
hiding behind that curtain at the end of
the story
and if you just take out that person
then the entire conspiracy collapses
like a house of cards that's the other
thing about conspiracies is that there
seems to be an easy solution which is
you take out the person who's at the
head
of the conspiracy but one of the reasons
that people are suspicious of the media
one of the reasons the conspiracy
theories are running
roughshod particularly on the right
these days and i think it is more on the
right than it is on the left
is because conspiracy theories on the
left are actually mainstream
so on the right there are conspiracy
theories and they tend to be fringy
moving over into the mainstream as
people react to the left
on the left stuff that is considered
basically untouchable
are conspiracy theories i mean the left
will say open things that are
conspiratorial
they will put out there absolute
conspiracy nonsense that is unsupported
by evidence
and the left will simply accept it it's
not counted as a conspiracy theory in
other words now we can all point to the
epstein suicide
and when somebody says it was trump or
it was clinton we can say that that's
silly that's conspiracy theory
but the left will put out there stories
that are obviously
untrue and that are in fact conspiracy
theories and the press will treat them
as though they are perfectly legit
they let me give you an example so over
the weekend msnbc releases
a documentary about stacey abrams
stacy abrams the democrat in georgia
she's a georgia state legislator who ran
for governor and lost by some 50 000
votes
she's been going around for literally
months ever since she lost to brian kemp
the actual governor of georgia
she's been going around for months and
suggesting that nefarious scheme was
perpetrated by brian kemp and the
republicans and that she actually is the
governor
now there is no evidence that she wins
that election none
she lost by 50 000 votes this is not a
close election
there's a lot more evidence that in past
cases like the washington state
gubernatorial election circle like 2006
that there was some voter interference
or that
the actual senator from minnesota in the
al franken
norm coleman election was was norm
coleman those were very close elections
where manipulation of a few votes could
have changed the outcome of the election
but when you lose by 50 000 votes you
lost the election stacey abrams lost the
election
it has become an article of faith on the
left that stacey abrams was legitimately
elected
governor of georgia and that brian kemp
stole that election
that is a conspiracy theory it is not
supported by evidence and yet it will be
perpetuated by entire swathes of the
media and the democratic establishment
so for example katie tour and msnbc
asked tasty abrams quote
do you think the vote was stolen from
you the election was stolen from you
and abrams replied i think the election
was stolen from the people of georgia
i don't know that empirically i would
have won but if you add together the
thousands of people
who faced extraordinarily long lines who
faced hurdles that should not happen in
democracy
the votes that we know are not counted
the secretary of state who is also my
opponent in the race
purged more than 1.4 million voters over
basically an eight year period
now she's still not naming the voters
who wanted to vote who weren't able to
vote
being in a long line does not prohibit
you from voting by the way that's just
called a long line
turn noted that kemp's so-called purges
were legal and were enforcement of a law
passed by georgia democrats who
dominated state politics for more than a
century
after the civil war registered voters
who don't vote update the registration
information file a name or address
change
sign a petition or respond to attempts
to confirm their address for three years
are moved to inactive status but can
still participate in elections according
to the atlanta journal constitution
and the washington free beacon if they
are inactive or don't respond to
election officials for another two
election cycles they're removed from the
rolls often times
the voters have moved out of the state
or died
abram said they knew people had been
purged from the roles who didn't meet
the criteria but didn't elaborate how
she knew
or who these people were she claims that
53 000 voters were put on hold by kemp
to prevent them from voting during the
race and that's deceptive
it is simply not true nonetheless abrams
continues to maintain this and she's
supported in this by figures ranging
from other democratic presidential
candidates
to columnists like jamel bowie people
who continue to suggest that stacy
abrams
is legitimately the governor of of
georgia
okay that's a conspiracy theory and yet
it's not treated as a conspiracy theory
it's just treated as a theory
it's treated as a normal theory everyday
politics i'm old enough to remember when
people were suggesting that if trump
lost the 2016 election
he would suggest that he had that he had
wrongly lost and that he actually won
and then we spent two years with the
democrats
perpetuating another conspiracy theory
which is that the russians were behind
trump's election that if it weren't for
russian interference in the election
trump would have won
and that trump and the russians were
actively colluding with one another
in order to move the election out of
hillary clinton's column
that turned out not to be true either it
took two years and what 12 million
dollars to investigate that particular
conspiracy theory but it's not a
conspiracy theory according to the left
according to the left trump still did
collude trump is still a traitor and we
should impeach him for this
this is the point i'm making generally
speaking conspiracy theories from the
left
are treated as extraordinarily
mainstream conspiracy theories on the
right
are fringe and then they gain some
momentum and it doesn't help when donald
trump
lends his weight to them whether you're
talking about birtherism or whether
you're talking about
what just happened with jeffrey epstein
but when it's on the left it's not
treated as a conspiracy theory it's
treated as something completely normal
i'll give you another example
that happened over the weekend
completely ignored by the media in every
conceivable way
we'll get to that in just one second
first
let me tell you about sleeping
comfortably so you know you spend a lot
of time
trying to sleep and maybe you toss it
and turn and you have a nice mattress
right when you got your helix sleep
mattress you got a nice mattress but
you're still not sleeping properly well
it's probably not because of the
mattress anymore now
it is because of the sheets that you are
using if you went down to the local bed
bath and beyond
and you picked up sheets at retail
prices and just picked up like the
highest thread count
these may not actually be fantastic
sheets and if you went down to the local
gas station and just got the thousand
thread count sheet and it turns out it's
just a plastic tarp
what you actually need is a really nice
set of sheets
you need bowling brand sheets everything
bowling branch makes from bedding to
blankets
is made from pure 100 organic cotton
they start out super soft they get even
softer over time you buy directly from
them so you're essentially paying
wholesale prices
luxury sheets can cost up to a thousand
dollars in the store but bowling brand
sheets are only a couple of hundred
bucks
shipping is free you can try them for 30
nights there's no risk
no reason to not give them a try try
bowling brand sheets you will indeed
love them to get you started
right now my listeners get 50 50 bucks
off your first set of sheets
at bullaandbranch.com promo code ben go
to bowlingbranch.com today for 50 bucks
off your first set of sheets that's
b-o-l-l
and branch dot com promo code ben
bullanbranch.com promo code ben
go check them out right now these sheets
are fantastic i sleep on them every
night we got rid of all of our other
sheets they are that good
bull and branch.com promo code ben go
check them out
right now okay so speaking of other
conspiracy theories
that are going to be completely ignored
completely and
wildly ignored by the media over the
weekend
was the five year anniversary of the
ferguson
incident involving mike ferguson
missouri involving michael brown michael
brown was an 18 year old
very large dude black guy who
according to the media reports at the
time supposedly
was murdered in cold blood by a white
police officer named darren wilson
and that was done out of racial hatred
because the police force in ferguson was
deeply racist and michael brown
was in fact surrendering at the time and
this is how you end up with famous
pictures on the news
of people like sally cohn and other
commentators raising their hands and
saying hands up don't shoot
and the idea was or i can't breathe they
use the eric garner slogan but hands up
don't shoot was what this became you had
nfl players in st louis running out of
the field
raising their hands hands up don't shoot
because black people were surrendering
to police
and then the police saying oh well
there's a black guy would you shoot the
guy down and michael michael brown was
used as the case in point
of all of this well as it turns out
that's not what happened at all michael
brown
had earlier in the day gone to a a store
a convenience store and he had stolen
some swisher sweets
which are very often used in the the
cigars they are often used in the
the tobaccos removed marijuana is put in
that's beside the point because drug use
really isn't the issue here
and michael brown assaulted the store
owner and then walked out
darren wilson the cop was driving around
town and he got some news
that criminal activity had been taking
place he saw michael brown walking
erratically with his friend dorian
johnson down the street
and he told them to pull over they
refused to pull over
he kind of pulled in front of them so
they pulled over at which point
according to witness testimony and
physical evidence michael brown
walked up to the side of the car punched
darren wilson in the face
tried to grab darren wilson's gun the
gun went off in the car
darren wilson got out of the car he told
michael brown to stop brown was running
away
brown then turned around and charged at
the officer this according to witness
testimony
okay and those witnesses are black this
is not a race thing
testimony and physical evidence dorian
johnson his friend lied to the press he
said
that he had he had turned around he had
said hands up don't shoot and that he
was actually
shot in the back by the police officer
the police officer shot him in the back
as it turns out
the wound pattern on michael brown show
on his body
showed that he was shot not only from
the front but approaching
that wilson was shooting at him as brown
was running at him and brown was a very
very large man he's 18 years old and
very very large dude
so that's not just what was found by the
grand jury in the ferguson missouri case
which touched off rioting in ferguson
egged on by the president of the united
states
who suggested that perhaps the grand
jury had come to the wrong conclusion
and that people weren't making up
stories like this when this was in fact
a made-up story by dorian johnson okay
the doj
did a full-scale investigation barack
obama's own department of justice did a
full-scale investigation
of the michael brown situation and came
to the conclusion that in fact it was
not a racial shooting
in fact it was a justifiable homicide
meaning that wilson shot
in self-defense he did what he was
supposed to do okay that is what the
obama doj found there was a full report
on all of this you had the grand jury
report and then you had the
and then you had the barack obama doj
report
none of these reports found that michael
brown was murdered none of them
it is an ongoing conspiracy theory to
suggest that michael brown
was murdered for racial reasons in cold
blood all the evidence is against this
including witness evidence
from the town and if you actually read
the witness testimony it's kind of
heartbreaking
in that particular case i mean we went
through this at the time in detail
the witness testimony in the case was
devastating because a lot of the
witnesses said that they had been
threatened by members of their community
for even coming forward and testifying
and that when the police tried to
investigate people would hide from the
police because they didn't want to blow
back from members of their own community
okay so with all of that as backdrop
here's what happened over the weekend
okay so over the weekend is the five
year anniversary of ferguson and
as i say dorian johnson the original
witness was lying by all available
evidence and it's clear
from the media coverage by the way that
he is lying still so the washington post
helps perpetuate this lie they had a
story called dorian johnson
witness to the ferguson shooting sticks
by his story
it's by wesley lowery who was one of the
reporters on scene in ferguson did a lot
of reporting from there at the time
he said michael brown was still lying
dead in the street when his family
gathered in the kitchen of a nearby
apartment to hear from dorian johnson
the friend who saw what happened
through thick tears johnson recounted
how he and brown 18 had encountered
ferguson police officer darren wilson
and how wilson had pumped half a dozen
bullets into brown's body
when johnson finished brown's family had
one request tell the media
and so minutes later a trembling johnson
was staring into a local tv news camera
uttering the words that would change
both the nation and his life
he put his hands in the air johnson said
of brown in his final moments
he started to get down but the officer
still approached with his weapon drawn
and fired several more shots and my
friend died the killing of michael brown
on august 9 2014 became one of the most
incendiary events in american history
spawning that spawning the black lives
matter movement most powerful rally and
cry hands up don't shoot
ultimately two separate law enforcement
investigations
concluded that brown did not have his
hands in the air when wilson opened fire
but controversy over johnson's accounts
ranged raged for months okay so now
johnson is speaking out
again here's what johnson says and it's
obvious from his statement that he was
lying in his first statement okay here's
what he said quote
his hands were definitely up when he
turned around whether his hands were up
or halfway up or fully down or up
he was killed and he was unarmed he
wasn't posing a threat
so in two sentences he denies his
original account his hands were
definitely up
whether his hands were up halfway down
fully down
or up he was killed and he was unarmed
he wasn't posing a threat
except for witness testimony except for
forensic
evidence all of that is true okay so
dorian johnson's still telling this tale
so as we'll see democratic candidates
presidential candidates perpetuated a
conspiracy theory over the weekend
and the media didn't care not only
didn't the media not care they saw it as
a sign of moral truth and decency
that these democratic candidates decided
to purvey this conspiracy theory
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about that cell phone
plan so your cell phone plan your bill
it's notoriously confusing we all know
it's impossible to know what exactly
you're paying for
those tiny hidden fees they're not so
tiny when you add them up no more
what you need is mint mobile mint mobile
provides the same premium network
coverage you're used to
but at a fraction of the cost mn mobile
makes it easy to cut your wireless bill
down to just 15 bucks a month every
single plan
comes with unlimited nationwide talk and
text with mint mobile
stop paying for unlimited data you're
never going to use choose between plans
with 3
8 12 gigs of 4g lte data it's the best
on the market use your own phone
with any mint mobile plan keep your same
phone number along with all those
existing contacts so you got nothing to
lose
ditch your old wireless bill start
saving right now with mint mobile
to get your new wireless plan for just
15 bucks a month get the plan shipped to
your door for free
go to mintmobile.com that's mint
mobile.com
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month at mintmobile.com again that's
mint
mobile dot com slash ben m-i-n-t
m-o-b-i-l-e dot com
slash ben go check them out right now
why are you wasting all this money on
your cell phone bill
just go spend less money and get the
same great coverage mintmobile.com
you don't need the unlimited data you
just need mint mobile mintmobile.com
okay in just a second we're gonna get to
democratic presidential candidates
perpetuating
conspiracy theories and yes this has
impact yes this has effect in the real
world but first you have to go over to
dailywire.com
and subscribe when you subscribe not
only do you get all the goodies you get
for 99 a year you get everything
including backstage
access you get you get this the very
greatest in all beverage vessels the
left is tears how to call tumblr you get
all of our sunday specials
on saturday get all sorts of wonderful
wonderful goodies not only do you do
that you also support us i mean this
let's be real about this the reason to
subscribe
is that we can continue bringing you the
content you love the fact is
the left would love to de-platform this
show just like they would love to d
platform most
right-wing shows most conservative shows
the left would love nothing better than
to go after our advertisers you help
insulate us
from a left that seeks to censor
everyone they don't like all you have to
do is go over to dailywire.com and
subscribe go make that happen for
yourself
dailywire.com makes a great gift daily
wear subscriptions 99
you get the annual and the monthly is
fine 9.99 a month but
99 bucks a year will save you tons of
money and you get the
vessel the beverage vessel so go check
it out dailywire.com we are the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show
in the nation
[Music]
okay so as i say these democratic
presidential candidates are perpetuating
their own conspiracy theory over the
weekend not a single question i saw in
the media asked about this not
one not one so very properly questions
asked about trump
talking about jeffrey epstein's death
and all of this but it is somewhat
newsworthy the democratic presidential
candidates
are just spouting absolute debunked lies
lies debunked by barack obama's doj led
by eric holder
about michael brown elizabeth warren
who's pandering for black votes
she tweets out five years ago michael
brown was murdered by a white police
officer in ferguson missouri
michael was unarmed yet he was shot six
times i stand with activists and
organizers who continue the fight for
justice for michael
we must confront systemic racism and
police violence
head on virtually every word of this is
a brutal lie
there's no evidence that he was murdered
murder has a very specific meaning
he was unarmed he was charging a police
officer at the time
he had already tried to grab the police
officer's gun by forensic evidence
the gun went off in the car witnesses
say that brown was inside the car he'd
put his head inside the car and his hand
inside the car
okay elizabeth warren tweeting out
absolute crap okay this is conspiracy
theory nonsense
and i guess the conspiracy theory would
have to include that obama doj that
found differently
kamala harris did the same thing when
she's not locking people up
she is apparently trying to justify
somebody charging a police officer
she tweeted out michael brown's murder
again that's a very specific word
murder forever changed ferguson and
america his tragic death sparked a
desperately needed conversation
and a nationwide movement we must fight
for stronger accountability and racial
equity
in our justice system so that's two
front-running democratic candidates
who are engaged in open conspiracy
theory suggesting that michael brown was
not killed justifiably
as per two law enforcement
investigations and a grand jury
investigation
no he was shot he was murdered he was
murdered beta o'rourke says five years
ago
michael brown was shot dead by a police
officer in the years since we've heard
too many names too many similar stories
to count
in each we're reminded of an idea as
urgent and as ignored today as it was
when michael was killed
black lives matter again you want to use
examples of black folks getting shot
unjustifiably
and there's a case in south carolina of
that happening philando castile was shot
wrongly in his car by
by a i believe an asian police officer
michael brown is a horrible example
and when you engage in the michael brown
mythology you're in fact engaging in a
conspiracy theory and this does
have real world effects the real world
effects
include continued failures in exactly
the areas that need more police officers
not fewer police officers you know the
fact that there are so many people on
the left
who don't actually seem to care about
what people
in the in crime ridden areas need
and yes many of those areas are minority
areas where there's high tension with
police
you know what you need lower crime rates
in those areas
okay this is it is wildly
and insanely ridiculous that the
democrats continue to push
the notion that police departments are
actually
the the enemy when it comes to the
the inner city communities that actually
do require
people to to police those communities
you need
lower crime rates if you actually want
to have a safer america if you want
these areas to be safer you need to
build trust with the police you need to
stop accusing every police officer
of being a murderer even when they are
not a murderer you need to
start recognizing that in order to build
credibility between police officers and
communities
you need to stop implying that every
police officer is a murderer when he's
not a murderer there's a conspiracy of
silence at the top levels of law
enforcement
then places like baltimore where the
majority of the police force is minority
where the police chief is black
that that police department is out to
get black folks
in ferguson you've seen a radical
turnover of the ferguson police
department
ferguson's police department has become
much much more minority the reason it
wasn't as minority before
is because they were having trouble
finding applicants frankly
but right now according to the new york
times more than half of ferguson city
council members and police officers
are now black but guess what that hasn't
changed the conditions on the ground in
ferguson nor has it changed
the attitude of many citizens toward
police because when you keep
perpetuating the myth
that police officers are generally out
to get black people it turns out that
has real world effects there's this
article in the new york times
it is called he's a veteran of up people
molded by ferguson's traumas
he's seven and it's a profile of a kid
named david morrison who's seven years
old
it says david morrison carries the scars
of ferguson's upheaval
a veteran protester he has fled gunshots
and tear gas marched with signs played
dead on the asphalt in years of activism
then unspooled after a white police
officer killed an unarmed black teenager
named michael brown i'm so angry he
shouts he is seven years old
so are you telling me that he's had bad
run-ins with police officers
he's seven or is it that his mom has
taken him to a lot of protests backed by
presumably these sorts of presidential
candidates
well as the article makes clear it is
the latter as the article makes clear
his mother was taking him to protest
from the time that he was like two
david's mother got involved in a citizen
journalism project after the shooting of
michael brown
and took david along to protest when he
was a preschooler
but one night after she had scooped
david into her arms and raced to her car
when gunfire erupted she began to notice
the toll
he jolts awake from nightmares on the
living room couch where he often sleeps
then cracks open her bedroom door to
reassure himself
she's still there david and his mother
were driving on a summer afternoon when
the conversation turned as it often does
in ferguson
to race and injustice david piped up
from the back seat
i can fight the police no you can't yes
i will
david his mother said you're going to
end up dead if you do that quit using
your imagination it's time to use
reality
okay seven-year-olds don't generally say
they can fight the police unless they
are told by their relatives that they
should fight the police that the police
are the bad guys
does it help when you have national
political figures lying
and saying that a police officer who did
not murder a black man murdered a black
man
is that helpful a detailed federal
review cleared officer wilson
of any civil rights violations and
largely supported the officer's version
of the story
investigators concluded officer wilson
had confronted mr brown in connection
with a theft
at a nearby convenience store then the
report found brown attacked wilson while
the officer was seated in his suv
and struggled for control of his gun
after a brief chase on canfield drive
the report said brown was moving toward
officer wilson on the street when he was
fatally shot
after the shooting ferguson officials
entered into a contentious agreement
with the justice department
promising to overhaul its court process
make new guidelines for stops and
searches
give police officers more training
require them to wear body cameras
progress has been agonizingly slow
and as it turns out crime rates jumped
in the aftermath of ferguson not the
opposite who did that hurt
law-abiding citizens in places like
ferguson
there's an article by justin hansford
who is a law professor
in the new york times over the weekend
he's at howard
university school of law and executive
director of the thurgood marshall civil
rights center
and this columnist says five years after
ferguson we're losing the fight against
police violence
well let's make something clear after
ferguson crime rates spiked
due to something that heather mcdonald
correctly called the ferguson effect
police officers
of whom i know many not wanting to go
into
situations in which they could be
dragged up on charges for simply doing
their job the way that darren wilson was
it turns out this law professor what
exactly does he think is the solution
to all of this he thinks the solution
isn't
more police and less crime he thinks the
solution is to end policing and prisons
altogether quote
in the five years since the uprising
ferguson activists have shifted from a
demand to stop killing us
to calls for broader civil rights and
human rights standards and appeals for
the ultimate structural change
an abolitionist ethic that seeks to end
policing and prisons altogether
end policing and prisons all together
this conclusion admits the law professor
dubious and far-fetched to many
is a response to the thoroughly credible
and highly researched position that the
use of the criminal justice system as a
tool of racial control
reflects its original design yes i'm
sure that this is going to be better for
all the people who are law abiding
in their inner city in their inner city
communities
i'm sure the best thing will be to
continue perpetuating myth that darren
wilson shot michael brown in cold blood
just like officers across the country
would do and that has no impact on
people's lives in these places
conspiracy theories do have impact but
folks on the left
are willing to go along with those
conspiracy theories so long as they
support their political agenda
and as it turns out i mean in a wild
piece the new york times is promoting
yet another conspiracy theory today that
conspiracy theory
is that the shooting in el paso texas
the white supremacist racist shooting
in el paso texas is due to i kid you not
rush limbaugh
sean hannity tucker carlson and
virtually everybody else
on the right who has ever been critical
of
law enforcement when it comes to illegal
immigration there's an
article in the new york times called the
new nativists
how the el paso killer echoed the
incendiary words of conservative media
stars
and it basically looks like that actor
from from it's always sunny in
philadelphia standing
next to the conspiracy board right i
mean it's just
them looking i mean they literally took
the the manifesto of the killer
in in el paso of the shooter the white
supremacist piece of trash
in el paso and then they scanned it for
the word invasion and then they went and
found other people who used the word
invasion and that apparently is enough
to blame those people
for the crime to link those people it's
so weird how they didn't do that with
the manifesto of the guy who attacked
the ice facility like three weeks ago
calling it a concentration camp so
they've all now become charlie day in
the conspiracy photo
there is a striking degree of overlap
between the words of right-wing media
personalities
and the language used by the texas man
who confessed to killing 22 people
at a walmart in el paso this month in
the 2300 word screed
posted on the website 8chan the killer
wrote that he was simply defending my
country
from a cultural and ethnic replacement
brought on by an invasion
according to the new york times it
remains unclear what or who
ultimately shaped the views of the white
21 year old gunman or whether he was
aware of the media commentary well
wouldn't that be the thing you should
investigate at morons
if you're going to perpetuate a
conspiracy theory about how he watched
lots of tunkr carlson then went out and
shot up in el paso
walmart maybe you ought to check out
whether we watch tucker carlson all the
time
and even by that logic maybe you should
talk with with the shooter in the
congressional baseball game find out how
often he
was stumping for bernie sanders and
listening to what bernie had to say
but the new york times openly admits
that they don't have any direct connect
between the white supremacist terrorists
who shot up in el paso walmart
and tucker carlson but they're still
going to push this it remains unclear
what or who ultimately shaped the views
of the white 21 year old gunman but his
post contains numerous references to
invasion
and cultural replacement ideas that
until recently
were relegated to the fringes of the
nationalist right
again i don't like the language of
invasion and i don't believe i've used
it
if i had i'm sorry i did because i don't
think that it is correct but i'm fairly
certain i never did because i never
considered it
a quote unquote invasion when illegal
immigrants cross our southern border
but and i certainly don't believe in the
idea of quote-unquote racial replacement
because i literally do not care about
the races
of people who live in america i care
about their ideas and their ideology
but the new york times decides that
because there is language that sounds
similar to stuff that tucker carlson has
said
they are now going to attribute this
shooter to tucker quote an extensive new
york times review
of popular right-wing media platforms
found hundreds of examples of language
ideas and ideologies that overlapped
with the mass killer's written statement
a shared vocabulary of intolerance that
stokes fears centered on immigrants of
color
again this is a conspiracy theory and
the conspiracy theory this one
is deliberately designed in order to
link together basic
conservative tropes about immigration
with white supremacism
this is how you end up with the new york
with the washington post running a piece
today on their front page
about how evil the trump administration
is for cracking down on welfare used by
legal immigrants
abigail house loner and nick miroff have
a piece today in the washington post
titled trump administration aims to make
citizenship more difficult for
immigrants who receive
public assistance they say
legal immigrants who use public benefits
such as medicaid food stamps or housing
assistance
could have a tougher time obtaining a
green card or u.s citizenship
under a policy change to announce monday
that is at the center
of the trump administration's effort to
reduce immigration
the new policy for inadmissibility on
public charge grounds which appeared
monday on the federal register's website
and will take effect in two months sets
the new standard for obtaining permanent
residency and u.s citizenship
the trump administration has been
seeking to limit those immigrants who
might draw on taxpayer-funded benefits
such as many of those who've been
fleeing central america
now again this is a good policy but you
watch as the rest of the week is
dedicated
to the notion that the trump
administration is racist for attempting
to curb
public welfare use by people who are
legal immigrants to the united states
if you legally immigrate to the united
states you should not be dependent on
public welfare
if you illegally immigrant to the united
states you should not be dependent on
public welfare
i mean frankly if you live in the united
states you should try not to be
dependent on public welfare but we have
no obligation to bring
in people who are then going to be
dependent on on the taxpayer dime
that doesn't make the country
economically stronger
but again this is all part of a
generalized push
by the left right beta o'rourke
suggesting that the terrorist attack i
mean this has become his his
thing that the terrorist attack in el
paso was motivated by president trump
again this is all part of the giant
conspiracy theory that suggests
that the entire right is tied in with
white supremacists who shoot up the el
paso walmart
he's changing the conversation and if we
allow him to do that
then we will never be able to focus on
the true problems
of which he is a part and make sure that
we get to the solutions and then you
reported this week
that his department of homeland security
has been begging the president
to focus on the kinds of threats that we
saw in el paso
and he's ignored them or willfully
suppressed
action on those ideas and those programs
and those policies that could have saved
lives in el paso
and across the country so trump is
apparently part of the problem here
kamala harris goes even further of
course because she always goes further
and she suggests that the trump
administration instructed the dhs
to commit raids against a chicken
factory in mississippi
specifically as part of a quote-unquote
campaign of terror those are
specifically chosen words campaign of
terror and they're obviously supposed to
connect to el paso
this administration has directed dhs
to to conduct these raids as part of
what i believe
is this administration's campaign of
terror
which is to make whole whole populations
of people
afraid to go to work children are afraid
to go to school for fear that when they
come home their parents won't be there
campaign of terror campaign of terror
and this is this is the language they're
using again
conspiracy theories on the right are
treated with precisely the sort of
disdain that they merit
conspiracy theories on the left are
treated as perfectly normal rhetoric
and then you wonder why people on the
right react strongly to the media
condemning trump over conspiracies
again trump is dead wrong to say that
hillary clinton has anything to do or
bill clinton has anything to do with the
jeffrey epstein
suicide that's that's silly there's no
evidence to it
and guess what a media that refuses to
acknowledge the conspiracism inherent in
saying that
that stacey abrams governor of georgia
and michael brown was murdered
that donald trump is complicit in a
terror attack at el paso and the tucker
carlson is responsible
yeah the conspiracism isn't just on the
right guys and if you actually want to
bring down the temperature
then you're actually going to need to
call it out whenever you see it on both
sides
i'll call it out from trump i'm not
seeing a lot of people on the left
calling out elizabeth warren today
over the michael brown nonsense okay
time for a thing i like and then a quick
thing i hate and we'll be out of here so
thing i like today
over the weekend i had the opportunity
to read a great piece of hard science
fiction called three loss lethal by
david walton it's really good so the
basic premise of the book
is that there are these self-driving
cars
and there are these programmers who have
designed the self-driving cars but they
come up with a system for making the
self-driving cars incredibly efficient
it involves building ai and then the ai
as
is want to do goes out of control
i think that it's a fascinating book it
does raise serious questions
about a.i and the nature of being
actually one of the great things about
science fiction i love science fiction
because it's idea driven fiction
very often fiction is emotion driven
fiction sci-fi tends to be ideas driven
fiction
david walton is great at this the book
is three laws lethal
go check it out it raises serious
questions about what it means to be
human
ai the nature of identity and it gets
there from
basically all of the ride share services
that you use right now so it's kind of a
cool entry point
uh it is it is worthy of the read i
haven't read his other books but now i
want to david walton's three laws lethal
go check it out right now okay a quick
thing that i hate
well a couple quick things that i hate
so first of all democrats
now apparently it's become an article of
faith that it's time to dox
people who back president trump's time
to go after them kirsten gillibrand
desperate for attention
failing at zero percent in the polls
kirsten gillibrand she came forward over
the weekend she said that it's very good
to go after president trump's donors and
try to shame them or hurt them
what about though what joaquin castro
the congressman did this week with
publishing the names
of some of president trump's top donors
it's publicly available information but
some would say he was targeting these
individuals is that helpful or is that
dangerous
given what you're describing those are
his choices not mine
i will call out racism when i see it i
will call out white supremacy
when i see it i will call out hate
and i will stand up against it in every
form
okay so yeah again she'll stand up but
she wouldn't do it that way but
still people have to be called that i'll
call out racism and hate so she's not
ruling out the doxing
guys giving to a political opponent does
not mean that you are an evil horrible
no good very bad racist i may disagree
with you politically but if we start
seeing each other in that sort of light
there ain't gonna be a lot of future
okay final thing that i hate today
l.a county supervisor mark ridley thomas
finally beginning to recognize that la
has turned into a trash heap
and it really is it's a garbage hole i
mean i've lived here my entire life
and the conditions the living conditions
here are awful open needles on the
street virtually everywhere
they're hoping people homeless people
living in piles of trash
there's danger of disease particularly
on skid row in l.a but you can't go
beneath a freeway underpass and not see
an entire homeless city
l.a county supervisor mark really thomas
says hey you know what maybe we should
do something about this homeless
problem we have a crisis
i'm essentially advocating with my
co-chair darrell steinberg
that we declare a state of emergency the
situation is not getting better
it's getting worse we should not adjust
to a new normal that
suggests in any way that people ought to
languish
on our street any place in california we
take
roughly a 130 or three people
out of homelessness every day in the
county of los angeles and 150
come in why because of the force of
poverty
therefore we have to act quickly a state
of emergency
the right to housing no more status quo
okay you think the right to housing is
going to solve all of this
you think rent control is going to solve
all this where's the housing going to
come from it turns out that a lot of
people here want to live on the streets
there are a lot of people who want to
live who are drug addicts who can't
actually last in housing or mentally ill
who actually need medication but won't
take the medication
they've tried exactly these solutions in
seattle and it's exacerbated the
homeless problem you think a right to
housing isn't going to bring more
homeless people to the city of los
angeles
we are living in an economy with like a
3.7 percent unemployment rate
and yet we're hearing about endemic
poverty creating the homelessness
problem in la
why was it that 10 years ago when the
homeless when the when the unemployment
rate was a lot higher
why is it that in the middle of the
great recession the homeless population
of los angeles was significantly lower
it has something to do with the policies
pursued by the democratic legislators
and county supervisors in los angeles it
ain't going to get better
until you start actually arresting
people for trespass until you are able
to rouse people and move them
until you are able to get people the
help they need by putting them in drug
cleanout centers even if they don't want
to be there until you're able to take
people who are mentally ill and get them
the treatment that they need
and so you're able to arrest people who
are willingly living on the streets
you're not going to be able to do
anything it's going to get worse and
these politicians are too gutless to do
anything about it because they're afraid
of being called mean
well guess what it ain't exactly nice to
taxpayers to have homeless people lying
face down and drug
induced in drug-induced states of apathy
outside your front door which all too
often is happening in the city of los
angeles you do not have a right to do
that
and affordable housing ain't gonna cure
that okay we'll be back here a little
bit later today with two additional
hours of content
if not we'll see you here tomorrow i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
robert sterling directed by mike joyner
executive producer jeremy boring senior
producer
jonathan hay our supervising producer is
mathis glover
and our technical producer is austin
stevens edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by jessua olvera production
assistant nick sheehan
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2019.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
clavin